الى هذه الصور المباشره التي تصلنا
للعاصفه الثلجيه التي تضرب ولايه نيويورك
في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه طبعا هذه
عاصفه تعتبر من الاقوى في التاريخ المعاصر
في الولايات المتحده الامريكيه حيث شلت
الحركه في البلاد بشكل همم كامل تقريبا
همم طبعا همم هناك همم عدد همم بالعشرات
من الوفيات جراء هذه العاصفه الثلجيه وهذه
الصور تصلنا مباشره لما يضرب نيويورك
بحاله همم غير مسبوقه لهذه العاصفه
الثلجيه في بافلو في نيويورك حيث تفصلنا
هذه الصور من هناك ونشاهد كيف الثلوج تغطي
كل الابنيه والشوارع وطبعا المطارات شلت
حركتها وتعطلت حركتها هناك وانقطعت
التيارات الكهربائيه عن مئات الاف من
المنازل طبعا كان هناك تحذيرات كثيره في
هذا الاطار من العاصفه الثلجيه التي تضرب
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه واضافه الى
اجزاء اخرى من العالم حيث شله الحركات
وحركه المطارات بالتزامن مع الاعياد اعياد
الميلاد وراس السنه
وتقطعت السبل بمئات الالاف من المسافرين